my dad wanted me to be aborted how did
you learn about that I was calling my
mom about abortion and I was like I'm
just so conflicted right now I know that
it's morally wrong that we were going
back and forth and my mom is incredible
at showing both sides of it she would
argue it from you know the perspective
of the mother she would argue it from
you know over protection of The Unborn
all of this would go back and forth what
makes the most sense and she was like
I'm gonna be very personal with you and
she was like when you know we found out
that I was pregnant
um Mike wanted you to be aborted and he
was like we knew our marriage was over
this wasn't obviously planned at all but
I wish you hadn't heard that I don't
think so no